là où ça bouge on va vous parler d'un
match extraordinaire qui aura lieu
samedi soir prochain entre laurent gerra
au zénith et laurent chandemerle ici
même au studio à bretteville
l'orgueilleuse patrice va nous dire
pourquoi il faut venir peut-être plus au
studio il sera de mauvaise foi mais ce
sera tant mieux
un match d'imitateur mais pour l'instant
c'est les trente ans l'artothèque avec
mathieu bellingen nous sommes à
l'artothèque avec l'éclair tangi la
responsable de l'artothèque qui fête ses
30 ans alors ici cette exposition elle a
voulu retracer ses trente années ce sont
30 plusieurs artistes ça c'est ça alors
l'exposition s'appelle avec eux et elles
constituent une sorte d'hommage à un
certain nombre d'artistes qui ont
partagé avec nous cette histoire fait
neuf ans que vous exposez que vous
prêtez une allemand c'est ça donc les
les oeuvres que l'on voit ici on est
sous l'objet d'une commande spécifique
qui leur a été faite à l'occasion ses 30
ans façon de marquer cet anniversaire
est de marquer cette fidélité que l'on a
envers les artistes
ce qu'on sait combien d'oeuvres prêtées
par an auprès de 6500 oeuvre par an six
mille cinq cents oeuvres qui sont trouve
alors dans le public chez le personnage
de particules ces sahraouis dans les
dents les appartements les salles de
classe les bureaux
les entreprises au centre de détention
et au moment où on parle là ça constitue
sa une population d'environ 20000
personnes qui vit au contact d'oeuvres
de la collection ce que ce que l'on
essaie de susciter c'est vraiment cet
intérêt cette curiosité peut-être cet
amour de l'art ensuite chacun fait à sa
façon tout le monde n'est pas
collectionneur mais
laisser quitter alors là nous sommes
dans le stock des oeuvres de
l'artothèque
alors il ya combien d'oeuvres en
totalité si clair alors il ya 2600
oeuvre en tout mais ici on a 300 à peu
près parce que le rsa est éparpillé
prêter exactement voilà l'autre sont
empruntés alors celle là par exemple cdu
qui ça ça me plaît bien alors celle-ci
est très bon parce qu'est jacques
pasquet voilà encore jeune elle libère
et je voulais emmener chez moi
absolument combien de temps et alors
vous allez vivre pendant deux mois avec
7,9 de chaque pasquet voilà grâce à
l'artothèque l'art appartient à tous
comprirent mois les arguments de patrice
pillards pour venir voir laurent jean
lemerle
l'imitateur ici au studio samedi à
bretteville l'orgueilleuse d'abord
l'artiste d'artistes est un artiste à en
tuer les gens limite ils reconnaissent
comme le meilleur
imitateur du moment et d'ailleurs
patrick sébastien dit de lui qu'il est
dix fois supérieur à lui-même mais c'est
normal sont derrière ce n'est pas un
imitateur qui fait de la politique on
est assez saturées comme ça c'est un
imitateur qui fait du show biz qui fait
de la variété
il est très connu pour faire des
imitations de chevalier laspalès bons
camarades et moi même avons une
proposition à faire ré une proposition
indécente
anja le pré ventes annuelles prévues
jamais le bout de ses pairs se fait à
perote passer une voyante réside
peut-être déjà fermé samedi donc vous
avez la possibilité d'aller voir laurent
gerra aux ngok où laurent chandemerle
ici même au studio de bretteville
l'orgueilleuse comme c'est à vous de
juger
là où ça bouge au théâtre à cherbourg
vous en avez marre de l'actualité trump
l'amérique et serra venez écouter de la
musique classique avec l'ensemble à
cordes magnetis au programme
donc
sébastien mouilleron votre spectacle
s'appelle america vous êtes vraiment
dans l'actualité on peut dire oui mais
par pure coïncidence parce que j'avais
pas prévu de faire coïncider l'élection
américaine avec ce programme qui est
prévue de longue date
c'est cette idée de métissage c'est à
dire que les compositeurs américains
prennent si vous voulez l'héritage
culturel européen et par contre font
autre chose que des compositeurs
européens gershon lui-même dit il faut
des pour la musique américaine il faut
des sujets américain donc en
l'occurrence on va jouer des extraits de
porgy and bess
et
il ya le rêve aussi du brésil de
l'amérique du sud et on y vient avec des
tangos de carlos gardel qui là aussi
sont vraiment le summum du métissage
america la musique classique en amérique
vu par quatre compositeurs
c'est demain au théâtre à l'italienne à
cherbourg